how about your boy uh drew brees why
he's doing interviews right now i have
no idea
yeah and they asked him and i didn't
have a problem with that fierce
what theo asked him no god no no i'm
sorry
who asked him uh he was doing like yahoo
sports yahoo
and they asked him about taking a knee
and the flag and stuff like that and he
said he where he [ __ ] up is where he
said
i would never disrespect the flag like
that
you know so but he he could everything
he said was perfect
except for that one line where he said i
would never disrespect right when he
said that i'm like
damn you remember in uh anchorman where
ron berkeley [ __ ] up and was like
[ __ ] you san diego and the guy was like
why would you do that
your poop mouth your poop mouth remember
that yeah that's how i felt when drew
brees did them like [ __ ] dude
you talk about a guy who's been a uh
all-pro uh pro baller for i think
13 years he's arguably been the best
quarterback in the
in the nfl for the last 10 years he's
mvp super ball
what he's done for the city of new
orleans is insane no player
on the planet has done more for one city
than drew brees if it wasn't for drew
brees and when they won the super bowl
after hurricane katrina all that [ __ ]
remember that and he donated recently
five million dollars out of his pocket
five million dollars gives back has all
these foundations family man
six kids what the [ __ ] he does you're
talking about the mr nfl he's mr
perfect he's mr perfect and then he he
said
everything is perfect except for the
disrespect part of the flag it's like
god you [ __ ] up bubba
you're [ __ ] up in this environment
it's not helpful it's it's not helpful
but also
but don't point your anger towards
because you got to remember where drew
brees is coming from i'm not defending
because he [ __ ] up and said disrespect
like oh dude
but from his perspective your point on
that why do you think that was a [ __ ] up
because salem nilan's disrespect to the
flag
means you don't understand why colin
kaepernick and these other
and reid and stuff and these other uh
players want to take a need
they're not disrespecting the united
states the reason
uh awareness to the to combat you know
the
the horrible you know condition that
comes to police force and black people
and black lives matter
so it's not a matter of disrespecting
the military in the america
it's uh they're taking a knee because
they don't agree with the current
i think he said himself this his whole
thing had been hijacked by
people who had other agendas too correct
yeah correct but but
you gotta really no one's done more for
a city yeah
in any facet maybe lebron ohio but even
that stuff correct no one's done more
for a city than drew brees yeah the new
orleans saints if one's for drew
drew brees they'd be the san antonio
thing yeah they were gonna leave
but look and by the way but also there's
so much more to point your guns that are
than
black better to point your negative
energy out than drew brees man he's one
of the good guys
you also gotta remember drew brees
grew up in locker rooms he's from texas
so he grew up in
very diverse locker rooms with black
people a lot of black people a lot of
black men
and he's been a leader and he's he's
been kind of the voice
the thing that's disappointing is when
you say and this i get why people are
upset
we can't ask for the man to lose his job
or doesn't make him a bad human being
because when he goes it's disrespected
like oh you miss oh you just
you you just don't understand death it's
tone definitely i don't understand what
the message is a little tone deaf too
now like giving but i guarantee you
if he watches malcolm jenkins response
he'll understand what the message is
did you see that i'd like to see it i
send it to dalia he blasts out
because you know deleted understands
sports and he goes can you know
check this out and i said well and i
tried to break it down for him
i said when malcolm jenkins comes out
when malcolm jenkins comes out
who's off he's he's basically the
captain of the defense
when you see him talk every non-black
person even black person if you're
uneducated on what
why it's important why why they feel
this way ostracize and
you know why they they're so adamant
about this is such a bigger deal than
you're making it
watch malcolm jenkins response and
you're gonna go holy [ __ ] i get it
if you don't you're sociopathic that's
what i mean is like that's why can we
play this [ __ ] yeah yeah that's why i
kept my mouth shut because you should
and you should because if you're not
involved
you know what sometimes it's okay not to
have opinion on things if you don't know
what the [ __ ]
it's okay to just just let people have
their voice first
and then this is going to come out
arguments are going to come out about if
this is not lost on people who are
people who are like there are a lot of
people who are into the black lives
matter movement who understand that
there are
nuances to this argument right now
though it's time to have an emotional
catharsis for
whoever and and and the nation has been
mobilized the world's been mobilized
and it'll change some cultures but it's
okay to educate yourself
and then have an impact correct correct
let me hear this okay
and if you don't know what to say you
don't have to say i'm saying goddamn
thing
but educate yourself on why the protests
are going on
not diluting the writing if you're
focused on that you're [ __ ] missing
the ball here that's right
but watch this and tell me that you're
not more educated after this
also real quick it's yahoo finance not
young sports not that thank you chad
communities are under siege positive
posit posit
so he he's one of the best defense
players in the league for a long time
he's basically the captain of the
defense
over there now and he's a veteran and so
it's gonna be drew brees it's his team
but it's also his team every
everyone respects him so you gotta
realize where he's coming gotcha all
right
good superstar hold on
and we need help
and what you're telling us is don't ask
for help that way
ask for a different way i can't listen
to it when you ask that way
we're done asking drew and people who
who
share your sentiments who express those
and push them throughout the world the
airwaves
are the problem and it's unfortunate
because i considered you a friend i
looked up to you
you're somebody who i had a great deal
of respect for
but sometimes you should shut the [ __ ]
up our communities
going on keep going still yeah
this is in the full club yeah so this is
the 42 second oh you don't have the full
clip oh no no you need the full you're
going to need the whole thing
this is it's important to listen to this
stuff yeah it's important but you can
also see you know when you read it in a
tweet or you read
like that you're like all right that's
fine when you see the whole thing how it
affects them yeah dude
and the passion you know what i know you
know what i know about being black in
america
not like not a damn thing exactly
nothing neither so yeah
so i'm i'm finally listening and look
look at this hey hey i'll get to lebron
james
hey by the way progress is being made
policing has gotten better
policing has gotten better it's become
more diverse
it is the police have done a great job
they have a ways to go though
everybody does everybody does
there you go four minutes it's important
the kids are funny because they don't
give a [ __ ] that we have to deal with is
[ __ ] crazy right now
drew brees if you don't understand how
hurtful how insensitive your comments
are
you are part of the problem
to think that because your grandfathers
served in this country and you have a
great respect for the flag that
everybody else
should have the same ideals and and
and thoughts that you do is ridiculous
and it shows that you don't know history
because when our grandfathers fought in
for this country and served
and they came back
they didn't come back to a hero's
welcome
they came back and got attacked
for wearing their uniforms they came
back to people
to racism to complete violence
and then here we are in 2020 with the
whole country on fire
everybody witnessing a black man dying
at the him being murdered at the hands
of the police
with his just in cold blood for
everybody to see
the whole country is on fire and the
first thing that you do is
criticize one's
peaceful protest that was years ago when
we were trying to
signal uh a sign for help and signal
for our allies and our white brothers
and sisters the people we considered to
be friends
to get involved it was ignored
and here we are now with the world on
fire and you still
continue to first criticize how we
peaceful
how we peacefully protest because it
doesn't fit in what you do
in your beliefs without ever
acknowledging
that the fact that the man was murdered
at the hands of police in front of us
all
and that has been continuing for
centuries that the same brothers that
you
break the huddle down with before every
single game the same guys that you
believe with and going to battle with
every single day
go home to communities that have been
decimated
drew on unfortunately
unfortunately you're somebody who
doesn't understand their privilege
you don't understand the potential that
you have to actually be an advocate
for the people that you call brothers
that you don't understand the history
and why people like me people with my
skin color whose grandfather
fought for this country who served and i
still protested against that against
not against the national anthem but
against what was happening in america
and what our the fabric of this country
is for or stands for
if you don't understand
that other people experience something
totally different than you
then when you talk about being the
brotherhood and all this other [ __ ]
it's just lip service or it's only on
the field because when we step off this
field and i take my helmet off i'm a
black man walking around america and i'm
telling you i'm dealing with these
things i'm telling you my communities
are dealing with these things
and your response to me is don't talk
about that here
this is not the place you where is the
place drew
i'm disappointed i'm hurt
because while the world tells you
that you're not worthy that your life
doesn't matter
the last place you want to hear from
are the guys that you that you go to war
with and that you can
consider to be allies and to be your
friends
even though we're teammates
i can't let this slide
wow powerful [ __ ] wow the most part
that's what i mean he's ever done but uh
like you know what i'm saying it's so
powerful you know my job is there just
listen and hear that [ __ ] man that
that's that's not some
that's not some liberal antifa guy
that's not that's a that's a man who
deals with things
here's the thing though so when shannon
sharp who i love shannon sharp
love shannon trump one of my favorite
people on earth but when shan sharp goes
on the
third version of first take on fox
sports and goes drew brees needs to
retire right now that locker room is
everything the same
that's the problem no no we know okay
we know drew's breathing he's a good
person yeah we know he's done more than
the community than anybody else in the
nfl yeah we're all learning
so now i assume drew brees i'm like holy
[ __ ]
you're right my back now you have an
ally now he can make the correct
changes and help him and be a bigger
voice for everything
but when you go nope you're out you're
you're off the island no no we can't
kill you
no no no no no change his mind changes
my that's [ __ ] educational
what he did was i promise you did that
not to help you
it helped me it should help you i've
been alive for a long time i'll help you
cat
i've been alive a long time i can mount
a lot of arguments i can find a lot of
arguments but i was i was talking one of
my oldest friends
kenny fikes who's black and grew up in
this country i i said i was saying
i was trying to pick his brain on this
thing and i i had some points and he
said
that's all true brian but not now yeah
not right now
that's not this is not the time to talk
this is the time to listen so it's time
to let this happen now let me dive into
lebron james so then lebron james goes
wow man posting the drew brees thing wow
man
it's still surprising at this point sure
isn't you literally still don't
understand why cap was kneeling on one
knee
has absolutely nothing to do with the
disrespect of the flag and our soldiers
men and women who keep our land free
my father-in-law was one of those people
men who fought as well this country
asked him a question about it and
thanked him all the time for his
commitment
he never found cat peaceful protest
protest offensive
because he and i both know what is right
is right and what's wrong is wrong god
bless you
here's the problem with lebron james
well lebron remember remember when those
those protests in hong kong were going
on remember that in china
well china is a huge market for the nba
and remember when that
i think fox on fox news when lebron came
out and said something
and she goes shut up and play basketball
and when the nba
was threatened with losing business in
china and hong kong because their
comments
what did they do they shut up and play
basketball
because they didn't want to deal with
the repercussions of financial losses
so with lebron you were all about that
your shoes are made in china
you don't stick up for that but then you
want to stay so if you're going to be
that way you have to be that way
all the time otherwise to malcolm
jenkins point
when he goes that rah-rah-rah we're out
man if you don't understand we're
[ __ ] out with lebron
what what what there's tons of chinese
people how about the factory workers
the the hong kong people they can't say
[ __ ] they get arrested
they get murdered yeah are you kidding
me it disappeared so so
but but then when it affected your
bottom dollar you weren't about the
cause
but now you are so you i can't have you
picking and choosing a good point
yeah it's a it's like dude
lebron can be right and wrong too you
know again
he's learning again like 100 i'm not
saying you don't want him out
i'm look at my [ __ ] shirt
i'm a lebron's might besides besides
kevin durant lebron's my favorite player
i think the
lakers are going to win the championship
and if i follow basketball i would agree
no they're gonna be good them in the
clippers
they're gonna because you know
basketball is coming back what's this
say
let me get this ad blocker out of the
way but you know what you can't pick and
choose
when you're gonna say oh they they're
mistreated they're mistreated when it
affects your bottom dollar where are you
at
when it comes your bottom dollar where
are you at man
what does he say here lebron james sees
the first time since the nba's trip to
china says rockets
i can hear it uh lebron james speaks for
the first time since the nba's trip to
china
says raucous jam was misinformed about
the
ramifications of the street and not
educated about the situation
so this is when that the houston gm was
like not [ __ ] in man yep
and lebron's like whoa he's misinformed
because it affects your bottom dollar
now you're telling people to be quiet
what's that sound like
yeah the same [ __ ] you're upset about
but that's across the sea so it's not
that big of a deal
that's my issue that's that's that's
fair that's a very very smart
again he's my second i've ride with
lebron he's my second favorite player
but he can be wrong and you can watch
him agree with him he can be wrong and
he can be
he can be i mean i hate him we as human
beings guys who are
listening you're young and you're trying
to formulate your view of the world
you're gonna have inconsistencies in
your thoughts and your beliefs i i do it
all the time
one of the frustrating things about
trying to be on the side of right is
that you are going to be
[ __ ] inconsistent and all we can do
is just keep
did this is a verb this is a verb let's
keep moving forward and trying to you
know what helps be in it
but you know what helps and it helps
since i met you is if when you
understand
history and these things have these this
has gone before
all around the world when you understand
history you understand why this is a big
deal
because it starts as a small didn't
become a really big that's right
so when you and everyone was mad at me
and brian for saying [ __ ] we're not
wearing masks
oh you guys you want people that i want
people to die what i don't want is my
government to force me to wear a mass
because it starts there then goes their
curfew and the next thing you know it
leads to some other [ __ ] that was the
bigger deal
it's not these small things these mining
these mining things aren't my new
it becomes that and it gets a really big
deal what you think's normal
at the time it's not normal exactly
that's exactly right that's exactly
right the [ __ ] is moving quickly man
and we're all just trying to figure it
out we're all just trying to this is the
dance
this is the peculiar dance americans
have been having this black and white
especially
dance this this weird dance and trying
to figure it out
and and and trying to create equality
this is
even what makes it happen i realize i
grew up in locker rooms
so to me the the the black people in my
locker rooms i'd have to deal
well my friends were black in the
neighborhood they were black but that's
that's all i knew
and then if we're in the locker room
they were treated fairly if not better
because they're so good at sports
so to i didn't grow up around those
weird biases but then you get out
like holy [ __ ] man it's a different
world hard pushing me to the real world
you know what i'm saying
yeah so drew brees is trying his best
now
but now were there was there a protest
last night saying [ __ ] drew brees
yeah there is no really for every person
that went out there said [ __ ] drew brees
do you realize what he's done for that
community you [ __ ] idiot yeah you
realize what that man's done for the
community
he should have a chance to apologize
educate himself
learn uh make amends and and move on
oh and also otherwise we're not
otherwise we're not changing anybody's
mind yeah cancel everyone assuming you
keep going you
get suppressed well no what you do is
you now you really create teams
and nobody wants teams well here's the
other yeah
educate yourself you you the point of
education but also let me just say this
the point of education is really
important is to understand the
difference between a good idea and a bad
idea
and and and to know when a bad idea
presents itself
you have to read broadly and widely you
have to listen
most importantly and and that's a
constant process
drew brees is now more educated he's a
better person than he was
he's he's a more compassionate person
he's he's able to kind of
put this into perspective education also
gives you [ __ ] perspective so
just be a little bit more what is the
word compassionate right
open-minded open-minded allow people to
make their mistakes
and try to change minds and try to
destroy
you can destroy somebody and cancel
somebody or you can try to change their
mind what are you doing to persuade and
change people's minds
that's the question and also when you
when you start canceling people
especially athletes when people go god
i don't like athletes or politicians
that just give these cookie-cutter
answers
well why do you think they do it because
if they say one thing out of place they
get
[ __ ] drunk destroyed through the
[ __ ] mud
destroyed by people who don't want
change they just want war
that that's the thing that's when
sheriff gets on twitter oh he should
retire right now that locker room's ever
gonna say
jesus christ dude what are you talking
about shannon that's not helpful
no it's not helpful no it's also not
true it's not true you know
no it's not true no it's not true no
because i mean he he can meet with
malcolm jacobs like dude edu
educate help me so when i talk to the
team i know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about yeah so i don't have a mishap like
or how about this
drew brees has a perspective as a white
man that's not the same perspective as a
man who's black like he said
and and that's why i kept my mouth shut
i don't know
but that's why macklin malcolm jenkins
said you don't know history
you don't mind you know what if i i said
this to you and i've said this before
maybe on this podcast
for as much as i've read about american
history i've said this many times
i'm always [ __ ] blown away and i've
read a lot of history and i've taken
courses on history not just in college
or in history
yes i majored in history but not just in
college since then i go to the teaching
company i listen to
a history of the united states one of
the things i'm always [ __ ] blown away
by
is the the constant and i'm just and i'm
not a liberal saying this
is the constant onslaught the assault on
african americans from being starved for
resources from being
redlined they were put why what what the
great crescent why is there a black
ghetto in every
city is it because black people want to
live that way it's because they were
called it was called red line they were
the only choice they were put into
[ __ ] neighborhoods you couldn't buy a
house you couldn't get a loan unless you
had great
explain for people you couldn't get a
loan when they when they made
properties they redlined certain
properties that weren't valued
uh good income housing yeah so the
minorities went there
yeah and then when they would go to
apply for loans at banks they turned
them down so they're forced to stay
there
while white person could apply for a
loan owned property yes
investment up through the 90s so listen
up through the 90s this was
and so so what would happen is if you
owned a house in a neighborhood
and a black family moved into that house
ready for this
it would lower your house's
value it would lower your your income as
a white person
okay and banks knew this everybody knew
this
and whether you want to say it or not
there go it was there was a con there
was an expression
there goes the neighborhood well how do
you get wealth through property yes an
investment so when a black
family moved in yeah and i'll tell you a
story when a black family moved in
it was there goes the neighborhood
that's what they would say
and your property value would go down so
what did they do this was a
this was this is when you talk about
systemic racism you're talking about in
the system
you couldn't get a loan for a house even
if you had the same
credit score even if you had a better
score than anybody was white
even if you were a doctor alert you
could not get a loan to get a house
in a white neighborhood you had to get
on the other side of the tracks
that is why it's called redlining that's
why they were black
and those those listen to this those
neighborhoods were starved of resources
as soon as there were budget cuts or
whatever they're the first they're the
first
communities that didn't get police
scheduling public schooling they didn't
get that that's just
a historical fact they have worse
teachers yes that's a historical fact
that's just a fact and so you have to
look at those things and how black
people have lived for this long
it'll make you more compassionate it'll
make you more understanding make you
realize the big picture that
it's a systematic problem it's a justice
problem yes why they're surprised
have we made progress [ __ ] yes how do
you change it
do you do do you rob undefeated stores
do you rob
no you go you go you you educate
yourself you go to that like
you go to the ballot box and you hold
then you and you vote you vote you vote
that's the only way you're about you
vote out
you organize what killer mike said was
true that's not a threat to white people
it's not killer mike is a [ __ ]
educated dude
he's not some far left liberal or
anything else
and you hear more and more of this among
black people including
the floyd's brother educate yourself
we're a peaceful family
don't burn down businesses chrissy
teigen and and uh john legend
they they're they're given money to bail
out um protesters all right i understand
i understand but there you could also
give money to i'd rather see that 200
go to bailing out minority owned
businesses that might go even a little
farther
after it's been burned down to the
ground let's not criticize anybody right
here let's not criticize anyone when
people say this is so
again educated stuff when people go oh
those places they get looted or broke
into
they'll just file for insurance well the
way insurance works
is in the it doesn't count for looting
doesn't natural does that it doesn't
work another earth
it doesn't work my daughter gets her
violin so they're ruined my daughter
gets her violin from a family
that there's a there's a music store in
santa monica it's owned by
a hispanic family that hispanic family
those children go to
uh and and i think uh yeah where my kids
go
and this wasn't known to me until my
friend jeff foley told me this
but that that that family is a hispanic
family
the two kids share a bedroom in a one in
an
apartment they don't have money they
sell musical instruments
that store was looted destroyed they
took all the instruments insurance
doesn't pay that back they're [ __ ] up
so we know that
we know that enough to make it we know
that we know that yeah give me some
whiskey give me some brown looking
um is that the 23 year old yeah i got
you bubble that's nothing like
there's nothing like injustice so drew
brees issued an apology
everything he said 99.8 of what he said
was
great especially on the mark but then
the when he the disrespect thing
but you see more nfl players taking
neither we're learning man as a nation
this this country was called the great
experiment
and there's a reason for that it's it's
i mean comments
this is drew brees talking or i'm sorry
uh instagram i made comments that were
insensitive and completely missed the
mark on the issues we are facing right
now
why did the interviews be on me drew uh
they lacked awareness
and any type of compassion or empathy uh
instead these words have become diverse
and hurtful
and have misled people into believing
that somehow i am an
enemy this could not be further from the
truth and is not accurate reflection of
my heart or my character this is where i
stand
and he goes in the whole thing it's too
long keep going
keep going i think it goes i and i love
this because i have
always in all capital letters always
been an ally never an enemy
i stick i'm sick about the way my
comments were perceived yesterday but i
take full responsive accountability
i recognize that i should do less
talking and more listening and when the
black community is talking about their
pain we all need to listen for that i'm
very sorry and i have
and i ask for your forgiveness that's
fear man
of course it is as a human being if we
can hey
hey were you the same person you were
when you were 16
if you're 30 right now were you the same
person you were when you were 25
and if you're 35 right now and if you
are you're holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] am i different yeah and i'm a
slow [ __ ] learner
so i have a lot of compassion for you
i'm a slow learner and i'm
and i've said it before i've been way
wrong way more wrong than i have been
right
i [ __ ] up in many ways as a husband as
a father i was
telling brendan yesterday i [ __ ] up
but i'm trying to get better and we all
are that's all i can do so just now oh
there he goes for him to admit that he
was wrong i think this leadership at its
finest
mario davis demaio davis it's a good uh
it's good saints linebacker
yeah i tell you what when count wouldn't
count out the saints win the super bowl
this year after this
it's gonna make them close tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue okay what's gonna
happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected